hi everyone uh welcome to this
afternoon's uh frankie program in
science in the humanities event
our distinguished speaker series
and we have a very exciting speaker
today we have the mathematician and
author jordan ellenberg and his top
title
is i prove a theorem and the house
expands geometry and poetry but before i
introduce our speaker for this afternoon
i would first like to thank richard and
barbara frankie for their generosity
in
funding and supporting the frankie
program and many other activities at
yale that cross disciplinary boundaries
and
give opportunities for scholars young
and old
to dare to try research projects
that are not confined to single
disciplines
and i also want to remind all of you
assembled that we are recording this
event and therefore all participants
must mute their videos
and as is customary for our events if
you have a question please go ahead and
put it in the chat
and our we tend to have a q a after the
talk unless uh
dr camp and i are keeping track of the
chat so if it's a burning question uh
we'll go ahead and ask it right away if
not we will bank it for the q a session
so it is my absolute delight today to
introduce our wonderful speaker uh
jordan professor jordan ellenberg grew
up in potomac maryland and it turns out
that matt might be in his genes because
his parents are both statisticians
he excelled in mathematics from a very
young age and competed for the us
representing the united states in the
international mathematics olympiad three
times
winning two gold medals and a silver
this i should point out is absolutely no
mean achievement to get two goals uh and
a silver that is super impressive jordan
um he went to college at harvard um
sadly you know the other place uh over
there and attained a master's degree in
fiction writing from johns hopkins and
then he returned back to harvard for a
phd in mathematics
after graduate school he uh did a brief
stint as a post-doc at princeton
and in 2004 he joined the faculty of the
university of wisconsin and at madison
where he is now the john d mcarthur
professor of mathematics
his research centers on fields of number
theory and algebraic geometry you know
the portions of mathematics that address
very fundamental questions
about the nature of equations and their
solutions in whole numbers
jordan's research has uncovered new and
unexpected connections between these
subjects and algebraic topology the
study of abstract
higher dimensional shapes and the
relationships between them
ellenberg was a plenary speaker at the
2013 joint mathematics meetings one of
the largest mathematics conferences in
the world and he has lectured about his
research
in multiple countries and multiple
venues
he has a ton of awards and honors and
recognition because i'm dying to hear
him speak i'm going to give you a very
abbreviated version
he was awarded an nsf career grant and
alfred p sloan foundation fellowship
he was a fellow he's a fellow of the
american mathematical society and a
guggenheim fellow an assignments fellow
so um jordan has been writing for a
general audience
about mathematics for more than 15 years
and his work has appeared in many of the
most illustrious outlets in new york
times wall street journal washington
post wired
boston globe and he is the author of do
the math column in slate
um his novel
grasshopper king was a finalist for the
2004 new york public library young lions
fiction award
his 2014 book so this is not today he
will be talking to us about his latest
book but as you see it's not his first
book he's had many wonderful books
before and i was first introduced to his
writing when i read his 2014 book how
not to be wrong
and that was a new york times bestseller
and a sunday times london bestseller
uh lives in madison wisconsin and is
speaking to us uh from his home today
and um in particular um i just want to
point out if you haven't already bought
it um jordan's latest book is called
shape
the hidden geometry of information
biology strategy democracy and just just
about everything else it's actually
there in the title everything else is in
the title so jordan without further ado
i am so delighted you're here with us
today i wish it could have been in
person
but um we can't wait to hear from you
thank you so much for coming
well thank you so much priya and thanks
to the frankies for making this talk
possible
i wrote a book about geometry and this
is uh
a picture this is the front of this
piece of the book actually it's sort of
a map of the whole book and if i were
giving a talk about the book i would
just have to cover all of these topics
in 45 minutes which would be pretty hard
to do
but maybe let me sort of zero in on one
particular aspect which is that if you
look sort of
very near the center of the map
uh
we see a box called poetry and i did not
expect that when i was writing a book
about geometry i was going to find
myself talking about poetry so very much
and in so many different contexts
and so i thought for this audience and
for this center it seemed the perfect
time to sort of spend a little time just
talking about where those connections
come from and what they seem to mean to
the geometers and the poets who
participated in them and i guess if you
guys have questions about any of the
other things on this map um and what
they have to do with poetry or geometry
i'll feel free uh to pipe in some of
them are some of these are names and
people who are going to show up in this
talk and others um
are not because we only have a limited
amount of time together
okay so if you think about geometry and
poetry
probably there's like one
number one
line
uh that you have heard and it's a line i
think
who don't know the source of this line
like know the line euclid alone has
looked on beauty bear and it's from the
sonnet by edinson vincent volley who you
see pictured here um
but this is not really what i'm going to
talk about in some sense i want to sort
of set this up as a little bit of
something i want to
gesture the antithesis to um
because malays euclid
presented here is this kind of
singular unearthly figure who kind of
gets blasted with enlightenment by a
shaft of insight on what malay calls a
holy terrible day and in malay's poem
it's kind of like there's euclid he's
alone he's euclid the rest of us are the
rest of us like maybe if we're lucky we
kind of get to hear beauty's footsteps
wandering away down a hallway or
something like that um
and that is not really geometry as i see
it and i think it's not really true to
the history of geometry that i want to
talk about today i mean look don't get
me wrong i mean i am a mathematician
that's my job i get a lot of benefit
from
geometry
being this kind of mystique that it has
for a lot of people
um it feels good when people think that
the work you do must be like mysterious
and eternal and elevated above the
common plane like people are like how
was your day at work and you're like oh
you know holy and terrible the usual
stuff like that okay so that benefits us
to an extent but it's not really true to
our practice
or the way we see what we do so we're
just going to kind of take a tour
through
some other views and how they relate
to this one so let me just
start um
with this very famous
dinner party
um
that takes place uh in the 19th century
and two of the guests are wordsworth and
keats
who you see here and
keith's at this party is kind of
trolling wordsworth he's by insulting
isaac newton who was a favorite of
wordsworth saying newton had destroyed
all the poetry of the rainbow by
reducing it to prismatic colors and then
he like he drinks this famous toast
confusion to mathematics and the sort of
party is divided between the people who
want to toast confusion to mathematics
the people who don't feel comfortable
with that um
like wordsworth um
later maybe i'll even read a little bit
of keats here because he later writes a
philosophy will clip an angel's wings
conquer all mysteries by rule in line
there's the geometry
empty the haunted air and nomid mine
unweave a rainbow so unweaving the
rainbow as you see here depicted by pink
floyd on the cover of dark side of the
moon um that's almost that's sort of
since then has become like a metaphor
for the mean thing that geometry does
to beauty
to nature uh
it dissolves it it breaks it down to
something that is much less
interesting um
namely mathematics
okay this was not wordsworth's view
wordsworth
by contrast saw newton as a kind of
transcendent figure exactly the kind
that romantic poetry should admire um he
famously called newton i guess it's not
a hundred percent clearly he's referring
to but it is said he's referring to
a mind forever voyaging through strange
seas of thought
alone that's a little bit like notice
that alone right that echoes what malay
said kind of the same vibe
um
similarly i mean that's from the
preludes and let me give you something
else from the preludes um
oh i don't know why i have a random
curser stuck in there sorry that's a
screenshot thing uh the the cursor is
not it's not it's not wordsworth but the
words are
um
mighty is the charm of those
abstractions those abstractions means
the abstractions of geometry to a mind
beset with images
and haunted by itself you know i never
noticed until this second
because i don't usually use that keith's
quote that keith says empty the haunted
air so
wordsworth and keats are both
popular as an antidote to haunting i
should make a note for myself because i
haven't seen that connection before um
but for
for keats that's good
because haunting is like the presence of
like true spirits that are interesting
and math is boring um
wordsworth
thinks it's good
uh to be charmed and to kind of
heal your hauntedness but he's writing
this is actually kind of crazy he's
writing
this is part of him telling a story
of it's kind of a crazy story of a guy
who's shipwrecked on a desert island
and he has nothing with him
but euclid's elements this kind of
famous book of euclids that lays out the
basics of geometry and he's like
completely depressed and alone and
hungry and in wordsworth's poem
um
he kind of soothes himself
this is the moment at which he like his
consolation
is the presence of euclid the presence
of geometry um it enables him to kind of
get his mind away from like all his
regrets um
i know that's kind of a weird story and
you're like why would
that seems like a little bit of a
rickety story for wordsworth to make up
and put in his uh
preludes and one thing that's
interesting about it is that it's
basically true he took it from the
memoirs of a different newton
john newton who i mean it's a whole
story but he really was shipwrecked he
really did have euclid with him um
and he's not so famous for this he's
famous because he then
goes back to england and gets religion
and he is the author of the hymn amazing
grace so uh
interesting story but
um
so this is wordsworth you a much more
positive view of what geometry can do
and the way he felt about geometry
he also felt about geometers so one
interesting moment is that he becomes
very good friends with william rowan
hamilton i don't know if that's a name
that everybody here knows but hamilton
is an absolutely central figure in the
development of 19th century uh algebra
and geometry sort of a child prodigy and
when they meet
it's this kind of
very classic may december intellectual
romance where uh hamilton is i think 22
or 23 but he's already a professor of
astronomy of mathematics uh in dublin
and the two of them absolutely cannot
get enough of each other they like go on
long walks and talk about everything um
part of that
is because hamilton himself
while being famous today as a
mathematician
um
also wanted to be a poet he really
wanted to be a poet and wrote poetry his
whole life
he was always very ambivalent about it
um
feeling like did he really
deserve it so
uh
at one point he renounces
poetry and of course he renounces poetry
by writing a poem about his
pronunciation of poetry called to poetry
and there's kind of a cycle he renounces
poetry then he's like i can't do it i
gotta go back for any poems then he um
he actually renounced poetry again and
wrote a second poem called two poetry
which i haven't reproduced here um
and he's constantly sending all this
stuff to wordsworth so after he sends
his second renunciation poem to
wordsworth um
he really wants wordsworth's approval
and wordsworth
he's really nice about it he it's sort
of one of the great
gentle
kind letdowns uh
in early history or wordsworth writes a
long letter to hamilton saying like
i really like your poems
they're really good i wish i could
encourage you to keep writing them but
the loss to science would just be too
great i couldn't allow myself to be
responsible for the geometry and the
mathematics and the astronomy that
wouldn't happen if i encouraged you uh
to keep
writing poems so that's uh
that's how wordsworth kind of handled
this rather delicate uh
social situation with his young friend
so
where are we um
i guess what
what we've seen is that what poets
traditionally think geometry is at least
poets of
wordsworth spain or malay for that
matter poets were sympathetic to john
great all they don't think it's just
some completely
boring bs that's meant to sort of drain
the world of its spirit which is what
keats thought what they think is that
it's some means of content with a
transcendence some means of contact with
something that is uh the same kind of
thing that romantic poetry wanted to be
in con
you could call it the divine you could
call it the transcendent something
beyond ordinary human experience so
what is geometers typically think poetry
is we should look at the other side of
it um
that's a little complicated we talked
about hamilton who i think has a pretty
mainstream relationship
with
poetry but i also want to talk about
james joseph sylvester who we see here
this is another
big time 19th century
british mathematician
um
maybe
famous by the way to everyone who knew
him for having a gigantic heads that's
not just the picture like that's he was
a guy who was well known by everyone in
the community for having uh a huge head
um
i said he was an
audition but he was almost the first
american mathematician um and maybe i
just i can't not
tell the story i mean
so he came to the university of virginia
in 1844
at a time when there was essentially no
research math enterprise in the united
states at all so this was a very bold
and forward-looking move uh by the
university of virginia to bring in
um
a really really strong young
mathematician from europe to kind of
start a community from scratch and um
it did not end well
and you know if you have anybody in your
life who likes to complain about how
entitled
american college students are these days
maybe you are such a person or maybe you
just have such people on your social
media feed or whatever um i just really
want to encourage you in the strongest
possible terms to read about what
american college students were like in
the early 19th century
because it will make you feel like we
now live in a paradise um
and part of the reason i mentioned this
is i got to tell a good yell story so in
yale in 1830
um 44 students
including the son of the sitting vice
president john calhoun were expelled
after they refused to take a final exam
in geometry that had been changed the
last minute from open book to closed
books and this was known at yale for
decades afterwards as the conic sections
rebellion
okay so the university of virginia was
not very different from yale at this
point in time it was very aristocratic
um
and what was appealing perhaps to the
faculty the idea of this distinguished
senior scholar was not appealing to the
students at all sylvester uh
expected obedience he expected attention
to lessons uh he did not treat the sort
of aristocratic mostly southern students
at the university of virginia with the
deference that they
uh expected and the semester ended with
sylvester um getting into a physical
fracas
uh using us
with an undergraduate uh thinking that
he had killed the undergraduate he fled
the united states uh
and went back to england and built his
career there and he did eventually come
back to the us to teach johns hopkins in
the 1870s but essentially that was
the cause of essentially a 30-year delay
uh in the founding of american
mathematics okay but really i mean
it's a good story but really i want to
talk about sylvester and poetry um
he said at the beginning of a speech one
time
um an eloquent mathematician must from
the nature of things
ever remain as rare a phenomenon as a
talking fish
it's a great line but of course it's one
of those self-deprecating things that
you only say if you actually think that
you're the exception right which is
definitely what sylvester thought
sylvester definitely uh was rather proud
of his verbal skill and in fact um one
thing he's known for is he coined
a lot of mathematical terms that we use
today um
you know
invariant discriminant probably the most
famous one is matrix if you've ever
taken linear algebra or even algebra 2
in high school or like scene action
movies like it's a word you know the
matrix that is a coinage um
of sylvester's
and indeed
like hamilton
um
sylvester was a poet he wrote what i
think
must be
the only sonnet
ever addressed to an algebraic
expression this one to a missing member
of a family group of terms uh in an
algebraic formula so i see some
mathematicians in the room so i think
this is a poem addressed to a monomial
um i'm not going to read this one in
full but you can like look at it and
sort of get its
vibe
um
maybe one thing i want to say about him
is that
even though he is a geometer he has a he
has a rather different view of geometry
than i missed him vince malay does
in fact in a stance you might not expect
a mathematician to have he doesn't even
really care for euclid himself here's
what he says um the early study of
euclid made me a hater of geometry
which i hope i may plead my excuse if i
have shocked the opinions of any in this
room
he was definitely the 19th century
version of these people
unpopular opinion that was definitely
his style anyway sorry i'll continue
this quote uh
if i have shocked the opinions of any in
this room and i know there are some who
rank euclid as second in sacredness to
the bible alone and that's one of the
advanced outposts of the british
constitution
okay so what he's complaining about is
that he feels that
people are too
attached to like the perfect euclid set
in stone
a thousand or more years ago he wants a
geometry that is more tied to real
things more tied to the physical world
and he complains about how um
british education is completely far
behind on this he writes it is this
living interest in the subject which is
so wanting in our traditional and
medieval modes of teaching he's talking
about britain um in france germany and
italy everywhere where i have been on
the continent mind acts direct on mine
in a manner unknown to the frozen
formality of our academic institutions
so
sylvester is a person who does not want
geometry to be up there far away he
wants to be down here uh with us dealing
with physics dealing with uh astronomy
dealing with the world that we observe
with our sensory apparatus um i would
say go so far to say he sees geometry is
of interest only in so far as it
captures reality and provides
insight
and as for poetry
he sees it as something which
like physics has laws
that can be defined by reflection and
experimentation
and that it's worth doing this that you
actually like learn something about and
understand it better by understanding
its underlying laws so
look i'm not going to say that
sylvester's view has really taken hold
as a mode of literary criticism but he
did sort of sit down and write an entire
book um
the laws of verse
otherwise known as principles of
diversification um and delivered it as
his opening address when he was named uh
the president of the mathematical
society
of britain so this was something he
really cared about and he thought that
geometric and mathematical techniques
really could be brought to bear um
on the study of literature and this is
kind of a running theme for better and
worse i'll show you an example of both
so
um
let's move to the 20th century the
beginning of the 20th century um
and andre markov
who was a a russian mathematician who's
one of the founders of probability
theory and
in particular the creator of what is now
called the markov chain and you know in
a different kind of talk
boy i could give i i could and in fact
often do give a whole hour on the origin
of the markov chain and the incredible
bouquet of applications it has in the
contemporary world um
i'm just going to say a tiny bit about
it what you are looking at
is markov's analysis
um so he invents this by the way i
should say just to win a theological
argument with another mathematician
about the nature of free will a very
strange story that i thought had to be
apocryphal and i i researched it for the
book and it's completely true
um
but later he's applying it to uh
to the poem eugene unagain
which this is not the way it's usually
typeset but he was writing its letters
one by one in a series of grids that's
what the picture you see here um and let
me just briefly say what kind of
analysis
markov does how does he make a markov
chain out of this poem
um
he says let me throw out everything in
this poem except for the pattern of
consonants and vowels
and what he says is you can sort of like
model this poem
please don't be mad poets i'm gonna
i'm not saying this with a poem is and
neither is markov but i'll explain what
i'm doing um
he observed by counting a lot of letters
and grids like i showed you in the last
slide that when you had a consonant
the next
uh
the next letter
was a vowel
66.3 of the time in other words most of
the time a consonant was followed by a
vowel and not by another consonant that
happened only about a third of the time
whereas a vowel was
even more rarely followed by a vowel
and um
and was much more commonly followed by a
consonant so you can imagine a kind of
imitation eugene o'negan generator that
maybe you start with some consonant and
then you say
okay i'm just going to random two-thirds
of the time pick a vowel and one-third
of the time pick a consonant and then if
i'm at a vowel 87.2 percent of the time
pick a consonant and 12.8 percent of the
time pick a vowel and just let that run
just keep on doing that for a long time
and then i'll get something that i might
call an imitation
of this famous poem by pushkin okay that
would be like a really really bad
imitation right this seems like an
incredibly impoverished view of what
this poem could be but let me make the
point that
even this incredibly minimal amount of
information is enough for instance to
distinguish two different poets so this
is what markov does in his paper the top
diagram is the diagram i just showed you
and the second one is a diagram he
produced from a novel by a i think now
mostly forgotten russian novelist named
aksakov um
and even this very meager model is
enough to tell the difference between uh
these two russian writers so
as i said i'm not going to tell the
entire story of markup chains but i'll
just comment that in modern usage
you can use models which are
much more sophisticated than this
but still much less sophisticated than
our actual like human linguistic
faculties um
to do a much better although far from
perfect job of imitating
text
mechanical production of something that
kind of imitates english language if
you've heard of
three it's a very interesting
contemporary example of a machine like
this but here's a simpler one um
what i did is just train the markov
chain
um to imitate baby names
just to kind of show you what kind of
information can be uh
retained by these kind of rather simple
geometric models of language production
um
you see three lists of
made-up names here right that my
computer made um
one of them i trained it to imitate
baby names from babies born in 1917.
another one i trained on baby names
for babies born in 1971 which is the
year i was born
and another one i trained on baby names
for babies born in
2017
and i'll bet
everybody in the audience
can tell
which list is which which is the list
that imitates 2017 names which is the
list that imitates 1917 names and which
is the list that imitates uh
1971 names so it's kind of cool i mean
it because it's clearly some of these
are names that are actual real names
some of them are names that sound
plausible some of them are names that
sound terrible so it's certainly not
doing the same thing humans do when we
make up names for our children and yet
it is capturing some interesting
features of style in this purely
mathematical way so um
i'm not going to tell you the answers so
i'll bet you all know um but if people
are not sure we can talk about it at the
end
um
so
and and this by the way this notion
i truly do not feel keats might have but
i do not feel that this is an
anti-literary thing to think about by
con on the contrary i think there is
actually like a pretty long tradition of
mechanical production of language
like writing like the data as poets used
to do um
in literature not as a way to produce
finished product but as a way to kind of
energize creativity as a way to
understand something about our
unconscious processes of language
production um
i do want to give one cautionary tale i
said for better or for worse um
somebody i wrote about in my last book
counted to me wrong
um was b.f skinner and his strength
with shakespeare um
so
i quote this only in order to object to
it but um
you know he wrote a famous paper where
he's like people say shakespeare
illiterate alliterates but i study the
mathematical mathematically and i say
shakespeare did not alliterate so he was
doing i think what
should
mathematicians should refrain from doing
um
we're here i mean just like mathematical
physicists should refrain from like
telling the universe what to do
um
we're here to understand things about
literature not to deny things about
literature that writers already
understand
skinner writes in spite of the seeming
richness of liberation in the sonic i
mean seeming richness
right
um
blah blah blah so far as this aspect of
poetry is concerned shakespeare might as
well have drawn his words out of the hat
and
i have to say when i looked into this
though i learned something interesting
um
skinner
like sylvester
like hamilton
wanted to be a writer that's what he
wanted to do when he was young he wanted
to be a novelist actually he didn't want
to write poems but he um he went to
bread loaf he got a nice letter from
robert frost like this was his thing and
then he just didn't succeed he tried and
tried to write he didn't couldn't really
finish stuff um and he had a lifelong
grudge against literature he wrote in
his journal literature must be destroyed
he was very angry so i mean um is this
funny that there's sort of a past this
great apostle of rationalism you see
sort of his like
childhood anger kind of like leaking out
into his uh
hostility to shakespeare
okay
um
we're gonna be together at least me
talking for about 10 more minutes and
then i'm going to take questions so let
me finish off
trying to bring us we're still like in
the middle of the 20th century here so
let me bring us uh to the present uh and
an actual alive poet there should be at
least one in any poetry talk right and
this is rita dove um
who is a former poet lord of the united
states who is now as it happens a
professor at the university of virginia
uh where
sylvester uh beat up a student with a
sword kane uh about 150 years ago
um
and i'm going to show you two of her
poems and actually because we have time
i think i'll read them because they're
great poems so and i and i did uh get
here fast enough
to do it so here's
you know most contemporary poets don't
even write one poem one math poem uh
dove wrote two at least these are the
two that i know so i'm going to read
them to you um
so the first one is called flash cards
in math i was the whiz kid keeper of
oranges and apples what you don't
understand master my father said the
faster i answered the faster they came
i could see one bud on the teacher's
geranium
one clear bee sputtering at the wet pain
the tulip tree always dragged after
heavy rain
so i tucked my head as my boots slapped
home
my father put up his feet after work
and relaxed with a high ball and the
life of lincoln after supper we drilled
and i climbed the dark before sleep
before a thin voice hissed numbers as i
spun on a wheel i had to guess
10 i kept saying i'm only 10.
okay
this is a view of math right a very well
depicted childhood story let me read
another poem of hers
which is called
geometry
geometry
i prove a theorem and the house expands
the windows jerk free to hover near the
ceiling the ceiling floats away with a
side
as the walls clear themselves of
everything but transparency the scent of
carnations leaves with them
i am out in the open and above the
windows have hinged into butterflies
sunlight glinting where they've
intersected they are going to some point
true and unproven
okay so two math poems i'm going to
leave this up for a minute but
extremely different in their tone right
poems which are in some sense about the
same thing as child learning mathematics
but they could not be more different
this second poem i think is in some ways
very close towards work what wordsworth
when he wrote mighty as the charm
right there's sort of something about
the
mentally
healing aspect of studying geometry but
there is something more here i think
than what wordsworth was writing about
maybe partly because wordsworth really
wasn't interested in mathematics as a
child he was an indifferent student he
sort of was interested in the idea of it
and people like hamilton attracted him
dove by contrast really was very strong
in math as a child and it's running from
her own experience and i think she has
sort of more
feeling for what it's actually
um
i think there's something really more
here in the distinction between the
between the poems um
again i could do a whole hour on math
pedagogy i'm not going to but this
distinction between memorization which
is what takes place in the first poem
and understanding
what just takes place in the second
right in the first poem it doesn't
really seem like her father is asking
her to understand something about
arithmetic he's drilling her in the
second poem uh
there's something else i just noticed
actually i've read this poem about 100
times by now but like
there is no authority figure in this
poem right
in real life there would presumably be a
teacher in the room where this happens
um
well maybe she's in school maybe she's
at home but if she's at home the
father's not in the poem if she's at
school the teacher's not in the poem
right it's just her just her and the
geometry and this is something about
what makes geometry special that makes
it jump out from everything else in
the the the young student curriculum
that you can make knowledge by yourself
you don't need a parent or a teacher to
tell you you don't need to rely on a
book that tells you what happened long
before you were alive um you can start
from the basic rules and construct your
own knowledge independent of any
authority figure to the point that as in
this poem the authority figures
completely banished and
this is this feature of geometry is why
um
geometry has often been seen as a threat
to the established order of things um
i i um
i didn't put this in my notes but i'm
just of course you mentioned that you
know newton we talked about who likes
him who hates him um he was certainly
seen as a threat
by religious establishments and there
was like he had his defenders wrote
books with titles like geometry is no
friend to infidelity um you don't write
that book unless somebody's saying the
opposite right
um so this idea of geometry as a kind of
liberation
that i think is very contemporary i
don't think i don't think it's really
there in the 19th century poets we
talked about um
except maybe in one place so sorry for
the bad reproduction of uh of this
picture but this is a picture from a
book called flatland i don't know if you
guys have read it so we're back in the
19th century in england now it's a book
by
edwin
abbott whose middle name was also abbott
by the way i'm going to have it have it
um
and let me just briefly tell you what
the story is about and if you haven't
read it it's kind of charming i
recommend it um it is this the book is
called flatland because it takes place
in a two-dimensional world
and the main character is a square
everyone in this world is a
two-dimensional figure you're so
is determined by how many sides you have
um
with you know triangles as the working
class squares a little better hexagons
very fancy circles are like the best um
and one day the square is kind of in
this house when
a circle a very small circle appears
in his house he's like oh my god there's
like some like baby aristocrat here like
what's going on and then something very
strange happens the circle starts
getting bigger and bigger
going before his eyes and the square's
like what
uncanny nonsense is this like this
makes no sense this cannot be happening
and of course well you can figure what's
happening because i showed you a picture
of it um he is being visited by a being
from the three-dimensional world a
sphere
and as the sphere
starts to enter his flat land
moves more fully into it and finally
immerses itself totally in the squares
two-dimensional world so that the plane
is cutting the sphere at its equator it
appears to the square to get bigger and
bigger that's the only way he can
interpret this three-dimensional moment
this three-dimensional motion and so
then what follows is this very um
this very long
argument where the sphere is trying to
explain to the square what the third
dimension is and square
just keeps on being like but it makes no
sense i mean you're saying it but you're
talking about something that doesn't
exist and finally the sphere is able to
convince the square the sphere says in
my world
there's a being that's a lot like you
called the cube
that's just like you except
three-dimensional
and he's able to sort of help the square
to reason about the fact that if there
were a being like him but
three-dimensional
it would have to have
eight vertices
and 12 edges
and six faces each of which was a square
like him and the square just purely
through reason
you know they go back and forth a bit is
able to grasp this
sort of um
actually i told the story in a bit in
the wrong order i would love it it was
just purely an exercise of reasoning but
in fact what happens is the sphere grabs
the square and pulls him out of his
world so that he can see
his world from above
and then the square really believes that
the square's like okay i've been to the
third dimension i can see it um
but here's what happens next it's sort
of an ironic moment um
we could talk a whole thing about like
the religious imagery here but i think i
won't do it um
the square having had this revelation
having been supplied this revelation by
the sphere
um
is very excited and it's like
now i get it now at last i understand we
were trying to tell me now i understand
why a three-dimensional version of me
would have to have these properties even
though i don't really have the sensory
apparatus to perceive it i can figure it
out by reason and what's more now i
understand what the four-dimensional
version of me would be like
that it would have faces for themselves
cubes and it would have like edges and
it would have 16 vertices like now i
understand everything and the sphere is
like what the hell are you talking about
there's no fourth dimension like that's
ridiculous like three is how many
dimensions there are you're not
listening to anything i said so it's
this it's this rather arch moment sorry
for the spoilers but this book is from
1881 um
where even the sphere is sort of like
locked into its prison of perception and
uh and that the square is able to go
past but again
it's because of the power of geometry
and because of the power of mathematical
reasoning that the square is able to
break free um from this prison of what
it is able to see to liberate itself uh
from the authorities of its own world
so
back to the present
um
what do we think geometry is now um
what i want to close because we're here
at this kind of nexus of science and
humanities is
i want to emphasize what i think is
really most present in dove out of all
the people we've talked about um
the geometry like all of mathematics is
fundamentally a human activity it's
something humans do for human purposes
and you know what i like to say is that
math
is made of people
so as much as there's an aspect of it
that we may feel is like beyond humanity
beyond ourselves like transcendent
relating to something that exists before
humanity was here and after humanity is
gone math as actually practice is
something we do because it's something
humans want to do and we do it for our
own reasons and i think that's certainly
present in dove but it's also present in
contemporary mathematicians let me quote
a wonderful quote from bill thurston who
um
i think anyone would say is one of the
great geometers of our time now
unfortunately uh deceased a few years
back
um
he said about math we are not trying to
meet some abstract production quota of
definitions theorems and proofs
the measure of our success is whether
what we do enables people to understand
and think more clearly and effectively
about mathematics
this is a point that i think is often
lost to people outside of mathematics
that our job is not or what we're
interested in is not what's true or
false
what's interested in what we're
interested in is
humans increasing their understanding of
what is in the world where that might be
the physical world or it might be the
abstract mathematical world um david
blackwell who was a probabilist like
markov another contemporary
mathematician he would have really
bluntly actually i think saying
something very close to thurston he said
basically
i'm not interested in doing research and
i never have been boy like imagine that
in your grant proposal right like we
don't say it in our grant proposal but
sometimes if we're being honest we say
it um i'm not interested in doing
research and i never have been
i'm interested in understanding
which is quite a different thing
and i think it's very clear that that's
what dove is
to that dove correctly understands that
interest to be what mathematics is about
you know so there is this stereotype i
think it's what sylvester called frozen
formality that what geometry is about
is locking our intuition into kind of
this straight jacket
of rigid proofs
i think keith certainly saw it that way
um but i think the way that modern
mathematicians like thurston and
blackwell see it is
much closer
to what dove is trying to get at closer
to the way i see it if you want my
personal opinion um
that it's about getting to a point in
dove's words uh that is true
and unproven okay so i'm going to stop
there
i hope there are some questions in the
chat because i left some time for it um
i will turn off the screen share
if there's slides people want to see
again i'm happy to bring them back
otherwise you can just look at my face
while i answer your questions
thanks everybody for being here
thank you so much that was super
exciting
and i would have liked you to continue
almost every story that you touched upon
i wrote a whole book you can go to your
bookstore and get that has all these
stories in them that's right
as we um wait for uh people to start
taking stock and type up their questions
um i would like to use this opportunity
to ask my own first
so um
so i think you've touched upon this in a
lot of your writing so there is this
question right there's this kind of deep
question about why does mathematics
actually work so well
in describing the world right
and in terms of how we should think
about mathematics
should we think about it as a system
that exists that we just discover in
nature
i think when i read bits of your book i
feel like that is sort of
you know it's a human endeavor and you
um
or do we actually actively create it
right and and i think a lot of the
tensions that you talked about you know
with geometry and uh poetry
have to do possibly um i wonder with
this question of agency right sort of
where
mathematics says so i would love for you
i would love to hear what you have to
say about that
yeah i mean it's sort of
a very old philosophical conundrum that
people have wrestled with right are the
truths of mathematics and the objects of
mathematics are they discovered or are
they invented um
what i like to say is that there are
things that we discover by inventing
them
um
and maybe that's a clever that's a very
clever slip slide through the
my clever way of not answering
um but there is some meaning to it and
maybe what i would say is that
of course as a working methodician
you cannot help
but feel
that the things are just there
and i think there's no reason
we have the luxury of not actually being
philosophers so it's okay for us to just
like indulge in those feelings you know
what i mean whether or not those
feelings um are correct or not they're
certainly useful
and usefulness
uh is what we
care about you know maybe i'll throw a
little psychology into the mix because i
was just reading something very
interesting that really resonated with
this for me i was going to write a blog
entry about it but i haven't done it yet
um where there's a certain style of
psychotherapy
where
they say people think too much about
whether the way they see the world is
like true or false like there's lots of
true things you could think and you only
have a very limited amount of attention
so the real question is like
which true things are you going to think
about
and i think that's very much this
um of math that the question of which
facts are true or false you know i think
those are facts but the really
mathematical questions is like which of
those things are we going to pursue
which are we going to see as related to
each other and which as you say are we
going to use because of the empirical
fact that
these objects that we think of are
inspired by and then feed back into
telling us stuff about objects of the
natural world whether they be
planets or poems
great so um
i'm waiting i see um aaron has raised
his hand could you please type your
question
in the chat
if i may we do have a comment
in oh you see oh
yeah uh just heard about the poetry
pavilion by s devlin in dubai
uh an address is provided in the chat
and was reminded of this by discussion
about relationships between consonants
and vowels
have you heard of this uh poet
jordan
no so i didn't they said the poetry
pavilion or they named a poet who i
don't know
s devlin is the poet
oh okay no it's not my poem it's not
about what i know actually and i
certainly
i mean
please understand that my what i know a
lot about his math i want to know a
little bit about his poetry so i mean i
of course sort of tend to like
lean on my favorites there's ashbury in
the book too but there's many more poets
i don't know anything about
uh
than those i do so in particular if
there's people there's probably people
in the audience who know wordsworth and
keats better than i do so i hope i've
like
accurately rendered
this tiny part of their views but i'm
sure there's other stuff in their work
that would be enlightening about this
stuff too that i just don't know
um
okay just wait a little bit more
yeah any other questions that are
showing up
i've checked that chat is enabled now so
it should be might not have been before
so
my question come in
okay it's up now
yeah sorry about that everyone we didn't
realize that the chat was uh
disabled
and as we wait um
you know i was um
well i have so many questions but it's
not fair if i keep asking all my
questions but um
okay while we wait
that's a really bad one and then people
in the chat will be like well i can do
better than that that's right like the
level of questions we're getting
well it's not possible to ask a bad
question because all this wonderful
stuff that you have so i was reading
about
um
you know you've also talked in in shape
about mathematical concepts
not just the words but the actual
concepts impacting even things like art
and that if you wanted to see
you could see the influence you could
really kind of map out and i love the
example where you talk about um
the um you know jeffrey hinton and then
you talk about you know clinton's
great-grandfather
charles who wrote a book and yet this
this um this phrase tesseract
that you know he he invented that word
and that you know um
that you could see this in dolly's
painting in crucifixion so i was just
curious
uh jordan with your frame when you walk
around and you look at things
are you i mean does the mathematical
abstraction always capture you because
it seems to me that
um you have such a
deep love for mathematics that
you see it everywhere
right and it is everywhere and that's
what you're pointing out to us
in um in shape
yeah i think so i mean i think you know
when you inhabit a certain landscape for
you know several decades as i have um
you're very attuned
to what reminds you
of that so it's it's definitely true
i mean that's in some sense my process
of book writing is that you know
a long time happens in between books and
over the course of that time like
i'm just encountering things like things
uh things in the news like things in art
or literature or whatever and you know
when it reminds me of math in some way i
kind of have a little file and like i
write it down and i create stuff and i
tend to trust my own instincts like if
i'm writing stuff down together there
must be something it has in common and
then i've got to sort of see what it got
so you know for this book
um
i think certainly one thing that
happened is i was like i had not written
very much of it and then we had a giant
pandemic and of course like everybody
else i was sort of spending a lot of
time
thinking about that and trying to get my
head around and trying to understand it
and
everybody wanted to feel useful like
everybody wanted to feel like the stuff
that they knew about was in some way
relevant so of course i was trying to
think about
what it had to do with math like what my
meager and impractical
life's expert expertise could possibly
have to offer and so that of course ends
up in the book right so in the end i
learned a lot about
you know the history of epidemiology and
the idea of diseases spreading through
space which is a very geometric
uh notion um of course
everybody saw that in an event that big
everybody's gonna see it through their
own lens and see a different
aspect of it um but that's certainly
that certainly is like part of my
process oh i have like yeah yeah there
are many questions that have started uh
coming in now i can read one out of
people i did it you did it yeah okay
okay from from aaron you mentioned that
geometry is often the thing that prompts
poets to see beauty liberation etc in
mathematics
do you think that there's a specific
thing about geometry that does this or
is it that students only or at least
first exposure to proof-based math is
through geometry
yeah awesome question and i feel like i
sort of set myself up for it with those
two poems of rita dub where she like
craps on arithmetic and then there's
like but geometry is great and it's
absolutely true
that
in a different world where arithmetic
was taught differently that experience
you had with geometry she could have had
uh
with arithmetic and the theory of
numbers like that certainly could have
happened
in our world
there's this very long tradition of
somehow seeing euclid's geometry as
primal
like the sort of
true thing that everyone that everything
else is kind of like a
slightly
dirty
imitation of so i think there's
something cultural and probably like
western cultural
um that causes people to reach for
euclid as this figure of purity that
causes you know what you know why
doesn't edna vincent lay say like only
di fantas alone has looked on beauty
bear you know what i mean i mean die
fantast was great but like
um
so i so i think it's culturally bound
and i don't think it's intrinsic to the
subject and to be frank
the lines between geometry and the rest
of math are not too firm and i think a
very catholic view in my book and you
know honestly some people complain about
it they're like i wanted more triangles
i frankly feel cheated i bought this
book and there were like
stuff about markov chains and stuff
about you know legislative district
thing and like all kinds of stuff that
like
it's true i have a very broad view of
what counts as
as geometric
so um there's another question
you know how can geometry help in the
fight against gerrymandering
a
great
question and i write a lot about it in
the book because i live in wisconsin
which has some of the most gerrymandered
legislative districts in the country
that's how uh i learned about this stuff
with the help of my colleague moon
duchen a mathematician and a geometer at
tufts who's really been on the front
line of this um
again i could give a whole hour and i
often do but let me give this sort of
three minute version which is to say it
doesn't help by telling us how to draw
congressional districts it doesn't help
by giving the answer and saying what's
the right thing to do because that is
fundamentally not
a math question it has math in it but
it's a political question what it can do
um i always say i can't tell you the
right way to do it but it can tell you
about wrong ways to do it it can
identify like really grievous offenses
against fairness
um and just kind of like put a fence
around
the most egregious gerrymandering uh
that helps create some space for reform
and i think i mean
if you guys i don't know how many people
in the audience are here in the us that
are following us politics but this is
going to be a big fight over the next
several months it's already happening in
some states including wisconsin
and absolutely there are a lot of
mathematicians who are um
providing real-time assessments of the
maps that people are drawing and helping
to shine a light on
what's being done
but i'm not doing it i just write about
the people who do it
i have another question to read out
do you have anything to say about lewis
carroll uh the participant and i agree
i've heard this too that alice in
wonderland has a lot of hidden and
unhidden mathematics
yes there's actually like you know in
the director's cut there's like a
deleted scene where i wrote a bit about
lewis carroll because he was very
interested in euclid and he had some um
i took this out because i thought it got
a little bit
too into the weeds in an early part of
the book where i was like writing about
euclid and his geometry but
um
you know we have this stereotype of like
okay euclid like
that's it perfection
300 a.d and it's all been downhill from
there right that's this like very like
it's kind of a bad cultural habit that
we have of somehow thinking like
everything was perfect in greece and
then everything since then is like a
sort of like bad carbon copy of a carbon
copy of that in fact euclid by modern
standards even though like somebody like
ended vince and malay would have been
told in school this is it the high point
of rigor and beauty and perfection um is
not rigorous by modern mathematical
standards and in fact the axioms that we
talk about as euclidean axioms today
they were cleaned up in the early 20th
century we usually use ones uh
there's a set by hilbert there's a set
by somebody else whose name escapes me
they're like because euclid was really
not up to the task of what we now
consider rigorous so so carol
um
he kind of had a critical essay where
he's like
come on like every english school child
like learns this proof by euclid because
it's what euclid said and it like makes
no sense like there's a stuff that's
completely messed up and he sort of like
wrote his own
uh which at that time was a sort of
pretty bold
thing to do but nowadays would be
commonplace like everybody knows like
yeah like i mean it's actually okay so
it's an interesting pedagogical thing
because there are places i have a
wonderful colleague of st john's and we
always fight about this they learn
geometry out of euclid which i think is
a terrible mistake
but i mean there's a certain sort of
habit of mine that says like well of
course you should like
go to the source but um
but that's not what i think euclid is
incredibly historical and important i
just don't think that's where you should
learn geometry now
thanks thanks jordan okay uh next
question
participant says i've read your newest
book shape and really enjoyed it
two-part question from this i'm curious
what your favorite mathematics book is
and what other books i should have on my
reading radar
uh
he knows i also work at a bookshop and
tell every customer about your book he's
also pursuing his bachelor's in applied
mathematics
i everything you do i love i love you so
much i love you studying math um
i i can't say that i have a single
favorite i'll say that
one that's very inspirational to me as a
writer and i don't even know if most
people would consider it um a math book
is uh is the book girl escherbach by
douglas hofstadter it's an old book i
read it when i was a kid probably about
50 times
and you know when i was a younger kid i
really didn't understand very much of it
and i skipped a lot of it and just like
each time i would reread it i would
understand more but i think so if you
know the book it's kind of this
meditation on like
ideas of self-reference um
[Music]
and ideas of recursion and it kind of
ties together like
mathematics theoretical computer science
artificial intelligence um
music and art and nobody else was doing
that nobody else was doing anything like
that and i just found it so inspiring
that you were allowed
to do that that you were allowed to be
like not just like physics like math
touches everything
um and just to get his playfulness and
his like willingness to sort of be
extremely serious but not stuffy um
that's kind of a model
for me um if you looked at the i don't
know if you would think his style was
like my style but it's sort of
inspirational to me to be quite honest
the other
i mean
yeah i know i think that's that's as
good an answer as i could give i mean
there's a lot of
we're in sort of a golden age of popular
math writing and there's like tons
of great stuff out steve strogatz his
books are all great those are like ones
that come to mind
um
yeah he's spoken in our series before oh
okay
why'd you ask him first no i'm just
kidding
he's older than me
um
well i think his um
this is when his book came out oh yeah
okay we tend to uh invite people uh soon
after as soon as after we can get them
when their books come out
um
okay so there's a question from one of
our frankie fellows that i read out
before wordsworth and keats james
thompson and alexander pope were
famously sparring in verse over the
poetic value of newtonian optics
and enlightenment sense more generally a
science more generally from the early
20th century into the present day
countless writers have registered
conflicting feelings about einsteinian
space-time geometry a system at once of
staggering beauty and almost unthinkable
destructive potential as we continue to
debate the social responsibility
entailed for example in epidemiology
models or mathematical climate models
are we rehashing the same old debate as
the one you highlight between kids and
wordsworth or do you notice any
interesting shifts across the historical
record around the complicated position
of maths and science in culture
it's a great question partly because i'm
learning a lot from it um i hope i don't
get like fired from frankie for saying
this but i don't even know who james
thompson is i know who alexander pope is
so um
so as you see i have like a somewhat
limited
view and don't know about this sparring
in fact i strongly encourage you if
you're willing to like email me and sort
of tell me where i should read about
thompson and pope because i know there's
like
a large history of which i know only
apart
um
but to the question
to the question
um
i don't think i see that exact keith's
wordsworth division when it comes to
things like
climate models for instance because i
don't think there's like
anyone who takes the stance
that oh we're just not
fully capturing like the glorious
richness of the climate by
reducing it to questions about
what the average global temperature
is right i mean you could certainly find
people saying that that's
reductive but
i think everybody grasped that that's an
important number that captures
an important feature and is not like
missing the point
that's what i would take to be the kind
of
kidsian view right if there was sort of
somebody out there who was like oh all
these people are like doing all these
hardcore numerical analysis models of
the climate like why can't they just
like sort of sit and enjoy like the
waves like coming down the street or
something like that right that's not a
view i think that is like
why maybe i'm being too specific but
here's where okay let me take it in a
different direction the the the place
where i think maybe i see it
is in these questions people ask about
the algorith algorithmized
self like people who are like okay does
like facebook know me and my friends
better than we know ourselves
right there's a algorithm that sort of
can track your internet usage does it
have some kind of
insight
into you that is in some sense deeper or
at least different um
than what humans have yeah so actually i
think that's the place where you see it
that and the sort of similar question of
like what you know what's happening with
machine learning and what's happening
with
ai like if we sort of say like and i do
write about this in the book like you
know if an ai plays chess very well
which indeed it does
um
does that ruining chest the way kate
keats
accused newton of ruining the rainbow or
does that enrich
chess
um and that is the sort of hotly
contested question certainly among chess
people
is that is that an okay answer do you
feel like tyler do you feel like
the
question you were asking but i took it
away from the things of real political
import epidemiology and climate so maybe
it's not the direction you wanted to go
with it
let me wait and see uh what tyler has to
say
okay i got some word
but please do rate me about pope and
thompson because i would love
to know
so um are there any more questions
uh did we um ty did you take a look we
didn't miss any comments or questions i
looked i didn't see any others
well let's just wait for um
another um
minute or so to see if there any final
questions
uh but jordan this was absolutely
fantastic
and um thank you so much for this
wonderful talk
and i so wish you could have been here
in person
but from another time i love that you
have a center for this by the way i wish
we had a center for science in the
humanities like what a wonderful
concept
um yeah and we would love to invite you
and have you come visit in person
so let's all thank uh jordan for an
excellent talk for
sharing his wonderful insights
across many many disciplines and
for getting us all very excited about
new ways to think about mathematics
thank you so much thanks everyone for
attending
um i just want to close with our um
upcoming events uh in the frankie
program
um we have a book talk uh another
distinguished speaker series book talk
by
hazel carvey
and we have a talk coming up by mariano
sigmund the neuroscientist
on december 8th and hazel's talk is on
november 3rd
so i really look forward to seeing you
all and i also uh remind you to uh
come and attend our monthly inference
colloquium series thanks everyone and
bye
you